it's et's late-night roundup your quick  catch up on all the most buzz worthy TV  scoop after dark  [Music]  well I saw her son Adam driver who plays  han Solo and Princess Leia's son in the  current Star Wars trilogy was a guest on  Thursdays Late Show with Stephen Colbert  the actor reflected on losing his  on-screen mother the late Carrie Fisher  she burns very bright you know and has  such a great very generous energy not  just you know who she is as a character  in the movie but her character kind of  missing from a very small unit is a  tragedy over on The Late Late Show with  James Corden Jamie Foxx kept things  musical putting a unique twist on these  classic jams  [Music]  [Applause]  Fox was a guest on the show alongside  Zoe Saldana who revealed just how  committed she is to her husband  you got a New Year's tattoo I did it's  here and it's my husband's face oh come  on be happy  [Applause]  [Music]  you